bruce willis legendary career is coming
to an end
in the most recent chapter of his
decades-long career bruce willis has
become well known for his prolific
output churning out more films in a year
than some movie stars do in an entire
decade 2021 saw the release of eight
willis features while 2020 saw four
movies make their way to audiences
technically five if you count as die
hard is bad commercial for die hard
come
batteries
you kidding me that productivity might
make it seem like retirement would be
the last thing on willis agenda but
sadly it seems his incredible career in
the movie business is now coming to an
end the news comes directly from the
actor's family with his wife emma heming
willis taking to social media to
announce a reason for the a-lister's
unexpected retirement the announcement a
collective statement from heming willis
and willis's first wife demi moore and
all of his children reads impart our
beloved bruce has been experiencing some
health issues and has recently been
diagnosed with aphasia which is
impacting his cognitive abilities as a
result of this and with much
consideration bruce is stepping away
from the career that has meant so much
to him this is a really challenging time
for our family and we are so
appreciative of your continued love
compassion and support
aphasia is defined by the mayo clinic as
a condition that affects your ability to
communicate whether it be verbal or
written as you can imagine this
diagnosis might have an impact on an
actor's ability to memorize and deliver
lines with that in mind it's
understandable that willis with the
support of his family would choose to
retire and place his focus elsewhere
heming willis has posted doesn't go into
any additional details about willis's
health status instead the willis
family's letter to the actors fans asked
for their continued support with a
pledge on their part to live it up as a
family during the actor's retirement
it's bittersweet to see bruce willis's
career end on this note especially for
long time fans of the actor many of
those same fans would have been holding
out hope that he could still one day
return to the kinds of high-profile
productions he used to anchor in the
past classic movies such as die hard
pulp fiction and the sixth sense to name
just a few nevertheless willis leaves
behind a truly impressive body of work
for audiences to enjoy his big break in
show business came in 1985 when
moonlighting became a pop culture
phenomenon he eventually parlayed his tv
stardom into a career as a leading man
in feature films with his big screen
leading debut in 1987's blind date then
in 1988 willis appeared in what would
become his signature role john mcclane
the hard luck protagonist of die hard
and its subsequent four sequels
audiences clearly took a liking to his
die hard persona as well as the movie
because it opened the door for a new
chapter in his career as both an action
star and a major marquee name the 90s
and 2000s i saw willis forge important
collaborations with some of hollywood's
most respected filmmakers of particular
notice a string of films with m night
shyamalan including the supernatural
thriller the sixth sense and the
realistic superhero drama unbreakable in
the more recent years of his career his
director video work has been broken up
by exciting returns to big screen
blockbusters willis re-teamed with
shyamalan for two follow-ups to the
unbreakable narrative universe split and
glass he also worked with director wes
anderson on the 2012 sharma moonrise
kingdom and that same year appeared
opposite joseph gordon-levitt and emily
blunt in the time travel thriller looper
the fact that willis has remained a box
office draw even after all this time is
testament to his enduring star power
making it all the sadder that he's now
closing the book on his one-of-a-kind
filmography
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one